[Music]
how many what's the percent of american
children
that believe hot dogs are vegetables
five the stupidest percent can be high
right better not be more than like 35.
one digit five percent anyone born after
20 like 17 who have had like the beyond
meets maybe they'll think that
so they're four years old
i think like maybe like a small
percentage like maybe
uh
five percent of kids now i say 25 holy
[ __ ] that's high any kid that thinks
it's a [ __ ] vegetable should get a
kick to the stomach dude or are all of
the hot dogs that are available at like
their school cafeterias like approved to
be like beyond meat or something so
there there is like a whole movement
oh wait till you hear the results i'm
actually
waiting to get the rest of it oh enough
though i've actually ate uh veggie hot
dogs veggie burgers because uh our
religion yeah yeah it's it's it's it
preaches against eating free of sin then
which is which one the seventh-day
adventist okay
it's free of sin it's free of sin right
sin free eating sin free hot dogs the
chicken is better without sin
modern day
salvation sausage salvation
unfortunately it's going to be like 40
it is 40 are you [ __ ] 40
40 percent you were lower than that
where believe that that's a lot of
kicking on my head to do man uh that's a
lot of guys joe a lot of doc martens to
the gun
you're gonna outsource these kicks bro
i gotta go to thailand and hire some
more thai dudes man just kicking the
[ __ ] has to be a professional i gotta
come come over right now man [ __ ] he's
he could probably kick like 20 kids in
like 10 seconds what motivation does it
what's the point of a parent telling a
kid that a sausage is a vegetable
because they probably don't know they
just interviewed the kids and then um
the kids believed that hot dogs come
from plants forty percent and more than
forty six percent thought that french
fries were a type of animal
they thought french fries wait how old
are these how old are they it doesn't
say okay they're probably like three
just as they're children if they're
three
you know what is it because they watch
those cartoons and they see those
[ __ ] hot dog corn dog plants yeah and
they have like yeah
and then they pull the corn dog and they
eat it they're like that's not a hot dog
have you seen those plants
in real life yeah with the cattail
things yeah yeah yeah yeah hot dogs the
corn dog yeah corn dogs
corn dog plants so this is basically
part of how we've disassociated um
food with ourselves you know due to
truth and education with kids that too
but you know kids aren't seeing where
this stuff's coming from like for for
example
41 were unable to correctly pinpoint
that bacon comes from an animal at all
they didn't even know we just we just
got dumb ass kids though what are the
ages of the kids like are they like is
it 17 and under so the ages between four
and seven oh okay yeah and it's 176 kids
from uh
around america
you know what's funny um there was this
like
chef that went around and uh all over uk
and he was trying to teach like kids how
like where their food comes from and
then like try to be more plant-based or
whatever right and then so they took the
kids to
you know see the processing of meat like
from where they're raised butchering all
this stuff and at the end you know all
the uk kids were just like grossed out
they didn't want to [ __ ] eat it or
whatever right he tried to do the same
show in america but had completely
different results
no like they did the whole thing they
went to the farm the [ __ ] petting zoo
all this stuff right they [ __ ] um
you know got ready to eat hamburgers and
then the kids were like yeah
and they just went to town with it
they're like [ __ ] it just don't
associate me with [ __ ] butchering and
all that [ __ ] it's like when i go to the
mission chips thing at disney and i'm
like man i can't wait to eat some
[ __ ] mission chips after this [ __ ]
but it's less visceral i guess wait what
do they do with the mission they do
visceral they do tours of how they make
tortillas yeah they show you how to make
the chips dude they show you how to make
the potatoes
yeah they show you the whole thing first
off first time watching super size me i
hella wanted big macs and stuff
afterwards oh of course yeah let's be
hungry right dude yesterday when we were
talking about mcdonald's it took me
everything to not pull into a
drive-through
like i was really like it took
everything from what's your moving
mcdonald's oh dude i do probably like a
maybe a big mac or a quarter pounder
depending on how i'm feeling and then
i'll do
side of nugs chicken nuggies and then
fries
and then maybe like a mcchicken
what's your choice of nugget sauce
sweet and sour good one yeah you know
and then sometimes if it's on a friday i
go fillet fish
that's weird i have to counter your
point mustard's good hot mustard is very
good how much is very good but yeah uh
food education is not very strong i had
a friend years ago and i actually got
into an argument with him because i was
like dude mcdonald's hot monsters what's
up he's like that's not real
he's like that doesn't exist wait they
don't have they do for the [ __ ]
nuggets right no he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah he didn't have it in his region so
he didn't believe in it yeah because
he's from boston and he beat the [ __ ]
out of him yeah i did i killed him
chowder in a little tin
how good said this yeah they get nuggets
in a bread bowl their [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know in europe they got a bunch of
curry sauce for the chicken nuggets at
mcdonald's is so bomb oh the sweet chili
in singapore yeah that's awesome yeah oh
so even chicken nuggets
which literally has chicken in the
[ __ ] name were categorized as a
plant-based food by more than a third of
kids
wow idiots
man they got shitty ass parents huh i
wonder how they asked the questions
maybe just didn't get brought up
but but i feel like most people in
general like they just don't understand
what they're eating and kind of i mean
that would have to mean you're a kid
that doesn't know what a chicken
actually is because if you know what
chicken nuggets are what do you think's
in a chicken nugget
what if all these kids are trolls yeah
oh yeah yeah that could be a tube
like vegetables so much [ __ ] smarter
than us they're like listening to these
idiots reading our stats
we got them [ __ ] morons
everyone has a different idea of what is
healthy but then
not knowing where your food comes from
that blows my [ __ ] mind dude honestly
there's a probably a [ __ ] ton of stuff
that i ingest i have no [ __ ] idea
where it comes from of course and i like
to think that i'm average educated at
least
so it's like hot cheetos for example i
don't actually know what i'm eating
that's a whole grain dude that's whole
grain that's good for you like what is
that what percent do you what it's corn
they mash up the corn and they puff it
really yeah so it's all corn it's corn
okay it comes great responsibility bro
digest it properly so
hold
what's
[Music]
[Laughter]
do you guys know what percent of kids
think that cotton candy's made out of
cotton
oh [ __ ] 100 100
uh 65. that's unfair though because when
i was in the game also yeah i have to
admit yeah i thought it was gone i
thought it was cocktail chicken nuggets
come from chicken but chicken nuggets
don't look like chickens are [ __ ]
trolls convince me otherwise
they're all [ __ ] get them in here
i always honestly assume that like
eighty percent yeah yeah yeah 75 yeah
cotton i would say 85 98.
three percent
god damn it
yeah they said it sounds like some
[ __ ]
yeah
are you [ __ ] with us yeah that's not
in here oh you ass
if only if only you know what though
it's more believable that they would say
that it is made out of cotton than
chicken nuggets not being chicken yeah
yeah for sure for sure for sure because
i like i don't even think there was a
time i was that [ __ ] dumb
you know what i mean like but there were
always those crayon eating kids right
like is that most of the kids nowadays
are they're just cranny eatings no
they're they're tide podied yeah very
good
i was pretty feral and pretty like
pretty nuts
but then i would still judge the booger
eaters though but isn't seven pretty
[ __ ] dumb too like seven yeah that's
pretty dumb you don't know anything four
it's understandable because you're still
learning about reality and [ __ ] yeah but
like you know like i'll ask my niece i'm
like what'd you do today and she's like
i went to a space and i'm like you
didn't go to the [ __ ] space
unless she's like
some kids are learning today though like
coding in class
yeah like like actual like elementary
school kids are like getting intro to
coding and the ideas it's lit yeah
that's super cool they don't know what
the [ __ ] chicken nuggets are what if is
is taika right
say some [ __ ] like this is chicken you
know like
[Laughter]
yeah part where you have park yeah but
how do you how do y'all feel about like
adults that are so uh
disassociated with where food comes from
or like oh i can't i can't look at an
animal before it like dies or anything
but they're like willing to eat anything
that's peanuts
that's [ __ ] pita dude grow up dude
peter doesn't work on asians [ __ ]
they just make us hungrier sure
this propaganda video like oh this is
where your [ __ ] duck comes from
the window statement the end of the
documentary all of us are like oh god
you guys want to go get some [ __ ]
pecking done
go eat any animal right now i can go for
any animal man i'll go to a [ __ ]
aquarium and i'm like
i want to go get some sushi after this
peter doesn't work on asians as a shirt
yeah it really is
kind of is we were at home trying to
guilt trip us and [ __ ] i'm like [ __ ] you
dude just make me hungry we were walking
to hawaii and waikiki and these guys had
tvs around their necks and they were
just holding them and i don't know we
were walking by we're like who the [ __ ]
are these guys and on the tv it was a
bunch of chickens getting thrown into
i've seen these guys the grinder and
nobody gave a [ __ ] dude
what's everybody going to do it's
[ __ ] hard to watch yeah some people
well i've seen some people do that at
the mall and then they're like they're
like wow there's like a small crowd but
over here nobody gave a [ __ ]
who cares it's kind of like go home you
can't it's hard to do that to immigrant
uh generations they're like duff where
do you think food comes from but then
they're so disconnected with the food
they're like dude you know this is what
happens it's like yeah this you're
eating death you [ __ ] morons that
they raise themselves dude
don't tell hawaiians that
dude they have a [ __ ] pig
that they grew from a little cute little
piglet and then they have a roast with
it like come on dude kick through it and
it's at the party where someone
graduates
they honor it yeah it's the way it goes
bro where do you think we get our
[ __ ] life from
you